welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to this episode we're covering the
recently released Netflix bloom house
horror movie mercy black the twisted
tale is full of metaphors and double
meanings and the film possesses an
ending that has a lot - impact from it
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about mercy black as well as what we can
take from the final few scenes this is
full spoilers ahead so if you haven't
seen the movie yet and I highly
recommend that you turn off now with
that out the way I hope you enjoy the
video now sit back relax and let's get
into my ending explain breakdown of
mercy black the film opens with the text
do you know mercy do you know her name
she'll take away you hurt if you promise
her pain instantly this sets the tone
for what is to be one of Blum Houses
creepiest projects to date the movie
itself follows marina Hess who 15 years
after mutilating a classmate is finally
coming home marina apparently committed
the crime in order to appease a phantom
known as mercy black now from the off
there are clear allusions to the
real-life Slender Man stabbing case that
took place in 2014 in which two 12 year
olds lured their friend into the woods
and stabbed her 19 times in the hopes of
impressing Slenderman similar to those
children
marinas crimes went viral and have
inspired many internet rumors stories
and copycat crimes that have given her a
level of notoriety in the area Marina is
obviously anxious at returning home as
she is haunted by her crimes and the
phantom of Mercy black upon learning
that mercy has become so famous she
feels guilt for bringing the world to a
whole new nightmare that she believes
has caused a lot of suffering
Marina desperately tries to convince
herself that Mercy Black was a figment
of her room
nation however her nephew Bryce becomes
increasingly more and more obsessed and
interested in the legend which leads her
to discovering that perhaps it wasn't
all in her head now right off the bat
this is a pretty heavily filled
jump-scare movie so if you don't like
them and let's face it who does and
you're probably not going to enjoy this
as much as you should to the film's
credit this is a far superior Slender
Man film than the actual Slender Man
film that was released last year and it
deals with the humanity of a story like
this with a lot more respect this is
down a lot to the actress that plays
marina who manages to display the
severity of mental health issues that
can cause psychosis like this as well as
convincing us that there could be some
legitimacy to the legend throughout the
film we learn that there are several
conflicting reports of a what mercy
black actually is some regard her as a
demon whilst others think that she is a
guardian angel when researching her with
help of librarian Lily Brice discovers
that she seeks outside children and as
long as they make her an offering of
flesh and blood that she will take away
their pain back home will Nylund
attempts to convince marina that she
should sell his story and make a profit
from it and when trying to grope her she
catches him with a sander which sends
him into a rage stranger things start
happening around the property and whilst
will initially gets the blame Bryce
asked Marina about where she has
actually been all these years
Marina confesses that when she was
younger she conjured mercy black as a
way to try and make her mother better
and with their friend Rebecca they
created this form of escapism in their
imagination to help and cope with the
problems in their life in the meantime
marinas sister Alice goes to confront
will about him attempting to scare
marina and she discovers that Will has
been writing a book on the story and is
obsessed with the ins and outs of the
tale well like most journalists believes
that the story needs to be told no
matter the repercussions and that night
he's attacked and killed by Mercy black
in his own home here we actually have it
confirmed that Will has been using his
friends in order to try and trick marina
into becoming interested in the story
again which sort of plays into the twist
at the end of the
anyway I guess it's good to know that
Dwight from The Walking Dead is
two-faced whether it's the zombie
apocalypse or not from here on out mercy
comes out in full force and we learn
more and more about the crimes that
marina and her friend Rebecca committed
as kids this involved cutting the finger
off their victim and feeding it to the
lake in the middle of the woods along
with their blood-soaked hands back in
the present marina goes back to visit
Rebecca who was released earlier than
she was and there's hints that Rebecca
was abused as a child which caused her
to begin to reach out for help from
Mercy black she learns that Rebecca
attempted to kill herself by hanging
from one of her father's ties but her
mother saved her and since she is turned
into a vegetable in her room Marina
discovers a map but she's attacked by
Rebecca who has to be covered by a
blanket in order to self down marina
flees the house and back home a price
ties of his friend and sets a trap that
will kill him upon his mother attempting
to help her it's pretty messed up and
there are hints that Bryce is struggling
with his father leaving which people in
the town gossip about openly though
Bryce let his friend go he states that
Mercy told him to do it as marina
travels back to the woods located on
Rebecca's map and she slowly inerts the
pastor remembers the original crime
which is when she discovers a fallout
shelter in the forest and we learn about
the truth behind the movie okay so the
first big twist comes with the fact that
the girl at Rebecca and marina
sacrificed is actually alive and well
and masquerading as librarian Lily Lily
has been grooming Brice for mercy the
entire time which is why she stated the
creature was a guardian angel and even
encouraged his research into her this
set off a chain of events in which he
attempted to murder his friend and
believe that Mercy appeared in the air
bent above his bed dr. Ward in the film
explains that as an adult
Lily changed her name and dropped off
the grid so that she would be able to
re-inflate society's new children we
learned that Lily wasn't even really a
victim in the original crime and was in
fact a willing participant
Lily similar to marina and Rebecca made
a promise to Mercy and throughout the
film has been tried to manipulate marina
into completing her sacrifice by making
it seem like Mercy exists in the end
that Lily takes Bryce back to the
shelter the resorts to threatening Bryce
in hopes that marina will kill her
however marina refuses and unfortunately
Bryce carries out
killing himself another big question
that many will have over the film's
ending is is Mercy black actually real
well this is a bit difficult to answer
but I actually believe that she is well
it's a lot of the strange occurrences
can be chalked up to living you or
marina psychosis there are a few things
that she could not have done and
unfortunately there's no way to explain
them beyond the antagonist being a
reality so how exactly did this happen
well the best explanation is that Mercy
was created through witchcraft which the
children were clearly practicing due to
the reference to a book of spells either
the characters believed a mercy strongly
enough that He willed her into existence
or their belief invited a dark spirit
into their life that took on the
identity of Mercy in order to have
people carry out its dark desires the
whole point of Mercy black is that
people must make sacrifices in order to
offer up body parts of the character so
that it can take them for example it
gains a finger and I through Lily losing
hairs and this ritual completes its body
in the end mercy ends of taking brights
and thus becoming whole able to wreak
havoc on the world once more and I took
the ending as showcasing that the
nightmare had truly began at you to the
sacrifice being completed the main theme
that can be taken from the film is that
ideas can actually become very dangerous
if they are shaped in the wrong way
mercy black started out as an imaginary
being but due to the publicity garnered
by the original crimes mercy went viral
and inspired a nightmare that spanned
the world just as well had the idea for
a book on the crime this eventually led
to his downfall
and it shows that if we do things with
negative ideologies and negativity is
all that can come from them just as the
idea of Slenderman was originally
created as an internet meme is
eventually spread to the point that it
created real-world crimes this showcases
the power that ideas have a mercy black
itself is a metaphor for the notion that
ideas if strong enough can change the
world in more ways than one and now on
to my review overall whilst Mercy black
starts off rather by the numbers I
actually think the phone picks up a lot
in the third act
it ends with a lot of questions and this
is always something that I look for in
horror movies it's a fun ride and
definitely stands as a good mental
health case study why the Slender Man
stabbing us may have happened so if
you're interested in that and I
definitely recommend that you seek it
out when you're next get a chance
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the film and if you enjoyed this
video then please like it and make sure
you check out my review of Pet Sematary
which will be linked after this video as
I'm sure you'll love it this is the
channel for people who were mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this I've been
definition you've been the best I'll see
you next time take care peace
[Music]